so there's there's the distribution of
scores now that's dismal that's a dismal
thing to look at you have to understand
that why look at this zero right
the median person has not done anything
creative ever in their life with
anything on any dimension right it's
really important to know that and then
you have these horrible people out here
right they do everything they do
everything price is law here's prices
law this is something to hammer into
your heart the square root of the number
of people in a domain do 50% of the work
okay so let's go through that you have
ten employees three of them do half the
work makes sense that's reasonable you
have a hundred employees ten of them do
half the work that's problem so the
other 90% are doing the other half who
cares about them you have 10,000
employees 100 of them do half the work
right so here's that here's a nasty
little law as your company grows
incompetence grows in it exponentially
and confidence grows linearly got it
right because it with ten it's three who
are doing half the work but at 10,000
it's 100 that are doing half the work so
nine thousand nine hundred of your
employees are doing as much as the best
100 you might not even know who the best
100 are but probably they know and maybe
their peers know too and so one of the
things that's really interesting when
big companies start to shake which means
maybe they've had a bad quarter too bad
quarters and the stock price starts to
tip down and the people the hot people
who have options are not very happy
about that and maybe they start to
announce layoffs all the hundred people
who have opportunities leave and they're
the ones who were doing half the work so
boy that puts your company in a pretty
rough situation because now you've got
the ninety nine hundred people left over
who we're only doing half the work and
the next time you announced layoffs the
next most productive hundred leave and
so then you're left with nobody who's
productive at a massive overhead payroll
prices law you can look that up to soul
a price the soul of price is a guy who
was looking at scientific productivity
and one of the things he found was when
he was looking at PhD students is that
the median number of publications for a
PhD graduate when he did his work which
was in the early sixties was one okay
half as many had to half as many as that
had three half as many as that had fork
surreal stepped out and one of the
corollaries of that is that there's a
certain number of people who are hyper
productive and that's these people out
here and if you were graphing the
distribution let's say you grasp how
many people in that population of 300
had $10,000 in their savings account
would looks very much like this some of
them would have or some of them some of
them would most people would have like
no savings whatsoever
the median person would have no savings
whatsoever and then you go up here where
the 1% is they have all the money but
the thing you want to understand about
that 1% issue that you always hear about
is that it applies in every single realm
where there's difference in creative
production every realm doesn't matter
number of records produced number of
records sold number of compositions
written so here's here's an example 5
composers produce the music that
occupies 50% of the classical repertoire
right Bach Beethoven Brahms
Tchaikovsky Mozart that's right those 5
ok so here's something cool so you take
all the music those people wrote 5% of
the music all those people wrote
occupies 50% of the music that of their
writing that's played so not only do
almost all the composers never get a
listen but even among the composers do
get a listen almost none of their music
ever gets played so so then that's
that's another example of this price is
loss scaling so when it applies to all
sorts of things like number of hockey
gold scores is also distributed this way
number of basketball basketball
basketball successfully put through the
hoop follows the same distribution size
of cities follows the same distribution
it's a weird it's a weird law and you
can think about it in part why does this
happen while imagine what happens when
you play Monopoly what happens everybody
has the same amount of money to begin
with right so then you start playing
it's basically a random game well some
people start to win a bit some people
start to lose a bit and then if you win
the hot probability that you'll keep
winning starts to increase and if you
lose your vulnerability increases as you
lose
and maybe you've got to say six people
play Monopoly soon one person has zero
what happens when they have zero they're
out of the game so zero is a weird
number because when you hit zero you're
out of the game so so then if you keep
playing people start to stack up at zero
right what happens at the end of the
game one person has all the property and
all the money and everyone else has none
right that's what happens if you play an
iterated trading game to its final
conclusion and that's part of the the
law in a sense that's underlying this
kind of distribution so it's it's really
it's it's not a consequence necessarily
of structural inequality it's built into
the system at a deeper level than that
so you know people talk about all the
time about how unfair it is that 1% of
the population has the vast amount of
the money and 1% of the 1% has most of
that money and 1% of the 1% of the 1%
has most of that money but it is a it's
a it's an inevitable conclusion of
iterated trading games and we don't know
how to fight it we don't know how to
take from the people who have and move
it to the bottom without instantly
moving back up to the top different
people maybe but still back up to the
top because even the 1% turns a lot like
I think you have a 10% chance if I
remember correctly you have a 10% chance
of being in the top 1% for at least one
year of your life and a 40% chance of
being in the top 10% for at least one
year in your life that's in Canada in
u.s. it's less so in Europe so there's a
fair bit of churning at the top and it's
not the same people all the time you
have the money but it is a tiny fraction
of the people all the time who have all
the money